maybe not all shoes are made for walking
especially not the ones supermodel
Christian mcmenemy sported during
Valentino's latest fashion show
it all went down at Paris fashion week
as Christians struggled to stomp down
the runway in a tight dress
but being that she's a pro Kristen
thinks fast on her feet ditches the
stilettos and finishes strutting her
stuff Barefoot on the catwalk I always
wanted to be different a little bit
different and I guess I always love
fashion I think the older I get the more
experimental I get after going viral for
her fall
the model poked fun at the incident
sharing a pic of last minute alterations
being made to her gown with the caption
before the fall in another post she
thanked Valentino while also taking
blame for the mishap
now Kristen had some celeb support in
her moment of need
yep that's Doja cat jumping in to see if
Kristen needed help during her fall she
was seated front row holding a bedazzled
bottle back just one of many looks the
star has been serving overseas
it's giving face and that's it yeah talk
about giving face Dojo looks
unrecognizable with brows a mustache and
a soul patch made from fake eyelashes
it's not too crazy the inspo behind the
last sheet look came after this stunning
display at scaparelli Dojo rocking
thousands of Swarovski Crystals but as
fans pointed out no falsies
foreign
[Music]
I'm obsessed obsessed and living for
every viral moment coming out of Paris
Fashion Week
[Music]
thank you
foreign